The Return of the King to his beloved
Santos was welcomed with flags flares
and fans singing his name as he was
transported back to the pitch that made
Pele a superstar his home ground Villa
balmero
placing him on the center circle one
last time was a little less smooth than
his fans had been used to seeing in life
it was a traditional open casket as his
family said their goodbyes with his son
ejinyo saying a quiet prayer
as the dignitaries started to arrive
they were led by FIFA president Gianni
Infantino of course we pay tribute to
him by being here we pay tribute to him
by asking all the federations now to pay
a minute of silence and tribute to Pele
but we're also going to ask every
country in the world to name one of
their football stadiums with the name of
Pele
the first fans to file past his coffin
had queued overnight desperate not to
miss their chance to reflect on an
incredible life
first in the queue was solo who traveled
from rural Sao Paulo to be part of
history
when I saw him lying there I wished it
wasn't him but that is the reality we
are faced with today there's no question
that man was Edison Arantes de nacimento
Pele the king he will forever live in
our hearts and memories for generations
to come
thousands have the same idea dressed in
the iconic colors of Brazil or the black
and white of Santos some making the
pilgrimage from all over the world
well I was born in Saint Lucia
originally and growing up when I played
soccer he was the first black person who
recognized as one of the greatest and
everybody on the island wanted to be
killing and when I moved to New York I
saw him played at the cosmos in New York
for Cosmos together with friends friends
Beckham she landed on a terrible day for
Brazil and thought I can't miss this
I've grown up with football I love
football and yeah I had to come here and
uh and share the uh pillow Center pride
of sharing this with her with everyone
that's here thank you because it's
he was the king of football and of
course players he'd been inspiring for
Generations
wasn't born here he didn't die here but
for 19 Seasons he put this place on the
map so much so that the Brazilian
government made him an official national
treasure and he couldn't play anywhere
else
he'll stay here until Tuesday morning
and after A procession through the
streets his final resting place will be
just 200 meters away close enough to
still hear the Roar of the crowd Jackie
beltrell Sky News Santos